ice green tea latte
with not with milk with soy milk
but only one third soy milk and the red
water and you always write h2o because
that's the easier way to ride water can
you guys do that
because you're quick and also
i would only like one pump of classic
not four that's ridiculous why does
anyone get four pumps of plastic
did you get all that um okay i think i
will
i would like a venti iced green tea
latte
with one third soy milk and the rust
water
and also only one pump of classic
did you get it with ice
thank you thank you you're welcome
so you started your channel in 2006 and
then you took some time off and went to
college and everything but you decided
to restart it how has it
changed now that you're redoing it kind
of for the first time
now i have a clear format
like so every week i'm going to be
posting music videos
that our original songs that my
my housemate christina wolfgram she
writes the lyrics and
we both kind of fidget around with the
melody and
sometimes i help a little bit more of
the lyrics but and then so i do an
original music
video that's about oh just any
any topic really the next one is going
to be a
lament a it's in this really
dramatic operatic style but the thing
that i'm so upset
about is that someone left ate my
leftover pizza
someone ate my leftovers and i'm gonna
it's like i'm
gonna die so just every yeah every
week a musical video and i think now
that my channel has a focus
i think people will be coming to it and
expecting that and they'll see that and
then the people that don't like that
will leave a little
more people who do like that kind of
thing we'll we'll start watching you
what kind of music style do you
incorporate in your channel
well because my background is mostly
opera
and classical i there's
it's always mostly influenced by that
kind of singing
and so it's either it's either opera or
a musical
theater or and then if i'm trying to
sing any other genre it's kind of sounds
more classical or more more like musical
theaters
and then and honestly we've kind of been
taking all different kinds of genres
like
from like kind of acoustic guitar like
mellow kind of sound to extreme opera
like oh like with the cadenza you know
big
like you know dramatic show-off-y kind
of type stuff and
to rap yeah like my abby go to school in
la video
how did you originally get into like
classical
singing because it's a very unique niche
ah
well when you when you're in school and
when you're studying it in an academic
sense
you study that's what you learn is
classical technique
because and that's that doesn't mean
like
opera singing or like oh it means it
just means like using your voice in the
most healthy way
where you're going to be able to sing
for hours and not have any strain
and people say oh if you know classical
technique you can sing
anything and really you can in the sense
that you're going to be
using your voice in the like the best
the best way
the best yet and then you're going to be
able to do the most with your voice
because you're using it
correctly how have really kind of
blended like not the old school not that
opera's old school but like
this very like old-school traditional
form of music with this like new
social media i guess just because the
things that i'm singing about
are i tried like i did the pinterest
song
which lets me i realized after i did a
lot of people don't know what pinterest
is
but yes they should and they should know
the dangers
of which my thoughts are addicting yeah
it's true
it tells people the dangers of pinterest
and so i just take i take a topic or
just i just make it comedic
so i take whatever singing and whatever
style or whatever topic and then i make
it funny
so
well christina and i just meet ever so
oft every week or so and just
brainstorm ideas and and then
sometimes the inspiration comes from
someone's
a user comment or it comes from just any
it kind of comes from anywhere but
mainly when christina and i get together
all these ideas just come out
we we just almost we just have
such so much in common and we're like
kindred spirits like
match made people who should collaborate
and be creative together because when we
you know when we come together we talk
about things
really ideas just blossom
what are some of like the future things
that you're working on now
um i said the lament
i think we're going to try and do a
halloween video
that makes fun of people's or pokes
pokes fun at people's obsession with
vampires as like love interest
so it's going to be kind of a song about
uh
how it's kind of ridiculous to be in
love with a blood
sucker and well you know like the pros
and cons of being
you know intimate with the vampire
in a silly way and uh
i'm doing a duet with my dad because
he's in town
and it's just gonna be a really silly
daughter dad and daughter do it it's
really this like
just really cute but then funny at times
i think that
we're gonna get the joke you know the i
am your father joke
in there because i did it the other
video i did with my dad was
when we were both playing around with
star wars uh i had a darth vader helmet
on
and then he had a stormtrooper one and
on and
so and then one of the jokes isn't it
i'm it's
a i'm glad you survived when i dropped
you on your head
it was like the truth is
like really every almost every new dad
has had an incident
like that like oh no
they'll never know about this though
yeah yeah
how made well how's it been i mean
you're balancing like being a full-time
student doing this
and are you auditioning on the side how
are you balancing all of this
um barely
uh actually being a grad student i'm not
in class
a lot of the time so i have all this
time
but then i just have to be very strict
with it
like set aside this is my time for
youtube and this is my time for
practicing singing and this is time for
homework and
i do better when i have more things to
try and juggle
because then my time is really valuable
and i make sure
i am allotting it as i should
when users go to your channel what do
you hope that they take away from it
i hope that it makes them laugh it
maybe makes them think more about the
styles of music that they're listening
to
and think oh like maybe this classical
type
more musical theater style is something
i would like
and kind of maybe make some yeah maybe
make some think about
looking at uh yeah other musical styles
and
but mainly just that it provides a
comedic you know little bursts to their
day
i always i've always liked to make
people laugh and
that's always been really the most
important thing to me
and then the messages that i get from
people if they say
i had a really bad day today and i
watched one of your videos and i felt
better
like that that's the that's the best
messages i can that's the best response
that i can get to hope for
you know they're cheesy
what advice do you have for people who
maybe want to start their own youtube
channel and they don't even
like how to begin how to set themselves
apart it's hard it's
so hard it used to be really easy it's
hard now
um i mean just just need to find
something that you're really passionate
about and then find people who
share your same passions and who you
get who get you and
and then find a specific format or focus
to your to your videos like a format
that you can follow
or just the general what kind of thing
you're going to be doing
and it just as long as you really enjoy
it then that's going to show
and then it's going to people are going
to be drawn to it because people like to
watch people having fun
and that's yeah really what my channel
is i guess still it's just me having fun
and being silly and
being a dork and having fun
what are your own like personal future
goals what do you want to do after your
master's program and with this
well i definitely i know that i want to
try and have a performance career of
some kind
and if that springs out of youtube great
if i win
the metropolitan opera auditions then i
get my career jump started as an opera
singer great
but i really i know i see a lot of
potential in youtube and so i hope that
i hope that some maybe i mean ideally
my channel will keep building and i'll
be able to make a career out of youtube
and then because really you don't you
can't really
hope to be an opera singer until you're
kind of older
and until then it's kind of a struggle
well it's always a struggle trying to be
a singer but i just yeah i just want to
perform somehow
or have be some sort of
comedian some in some form
how do you feel like youtube's really
been an asset in your singing career
uh just just that i know all about
all the social media is really helpful
because most singers are pretty clueless
about twitter and stuff like that and
and just to have kind of a a following
that is interested in what i'm doing and
interested in my singing
i'm eventually going to have my songs on
itunes and
i think eventually i'll start putting
classical and
opera songs on itunes and if people like
my silly original music videos maybe
they'll like my
my you know my academic classical
chosen career path singing too which
which i mean people i think people are
unaware of a lot of the
amazing music that yeah is from 100
years ago
but it is beautiful and it's inspire
inspiring and
and just a pleasure to listen to so
yeah how do you work to build a
relationship with your audience and make
it
like a personal connection
that that video i had i took it off for
a while ago
for a like i want to have a meaningful
youtube
relationship with you i meant to
do i did i mean the main thing i meant
was i want us to feel like
and i think about people look for
someone who they can relate to someone
who they
feel like is their friend who's talking
directly to them
who they kind of know about and
i i really in some way would like to
know about
my my audience and right now
my audience of people that i really
interact with is very small
so i i do read messages and i do look at
the comments
and for big youtubers they really that's
not
it's not possible it really is there's
too much coming at them but for me
like i i like to be i like to have feel
like i'm in a conversation with my
viewers
and that's easy because because youtube
has become this thing where youtube's
youtubers are almost celebrities that
you can't really hope to
like maybe to have a conversation with
they're like that they'll read your
comment but it's not like that for me
highlighter this is a green highlighter
it's from sharpie my sharpen
i have like 10 million sharp color
highlighters staples
no it's not it's not sharpie it's
staples but it looks like sharpie so
they're probably imitating shopping
this is my favorite
i cannot freestyle to save my life
oh here's my drink
don't be sad
he's a pirate
i am abby girl and you can also check
out my channel
it's abby girl and if you want to see
more videos of me singing
then you should go to my channel because
there's lots of that there
that's the best thing i've ever been a
part of oh my god i want to live in a
world where pinterest
is a reality